البدايه من التطورات المتلاحقه في الاراضي
الفلسطينيه حيث افادت اذاعه الجيش
الاسرائيلي ان قوه عسكريه اسرائيليه قتلت
فلسطينيا واعتقلت اثنين اخرين بعد محاصره
منزل قرب طول كرمه وقالت مصادر اعلاميه
اسرائيليه ان وحده من المستعربين هي من
اغتالت الشاب الفلسطيني
تنضم الينا من غرب رام الله مراسله
الجزيره جيفارا البديري جيفارا نتابع معك
ما يجري في طول كارما ما هي التفاصيل
المتوفره لديك بدايه
وفق وزاره الصحه الفلسطينيه الشهيده هو
امير عماد ابو خديجه ويبلغ من العمر 25
عاما وفق مصادر اسرائيليه فان وحده من
المستعربين حاصرت منزل في منطقه تعرف
بعزبه شوفه وهي جنوب شرق طول كارما وخلال
محاصره هذا المنزل قام وفق الادعاءات
الاسرائيليه
باطلاق النار على قوه من هذه الوحدات التي
وصلت وحصلت المنزل فقامت فقام عدد من
عناصر الوحده باطلاق النار عليه مباشره
فاصيب برصاصه قاتله في الراس وتم اعتقال
شابين اخرين كان معه في داخل هذا المنزل
وايضا وفق المصادر
الاسرائيليه فان هذا الشاب كان مطلوبا لدى
قوات الاحتلال وهو من احدى فرق المقاومه
الفلسطينيه وانه تم العثور بحوزته على
سلاح وتم مصادره هذا السلاح وزاره الصحه
الفلسطينيه اكدت بانه تم نقل الشهيد الى
مستشفى ثابت ثابت في داخل مدينه طولكرم
وانه وصل
والجمجمه تقريبا مهتكه يعني يعني في وضع
صعب جدا لهذا ما نستطيع ان نقول حتى
اللحظه العمليه يبدو انها انتهت وفق مصادر
في اذاعه الجيش الاسرائيلي وان هذه القوات
انسحبت بالطبع عاده عند دخول وحده
المستعربين يتم على الفور دعم هذه الوحده
انكشف امرها بتعزيزات من قوات الاحتلال
ودوريات تابعه للجيش الاسرائيلي وهذا ما
حدث اليوم يعني
يعني بعد اطلاق النار من قبل وحده
المستعربين وتبادل اطلاق النار بين الشهيد
ابو خديجه وهذه الوحده دخلت قوات معززه من
قوات الاحتلال الى هذه العزبه هي قريه
صغيره جدا في جنوب طول كارما
على الفور بعد ذلك انسحبت قوات الاحتلال
نحن في اليوم الاول من الشهر الفضيل يعني
كان بيودنا ان نقول كل عام وانتم بخير
ولكن يعني الاوضاع يعني لا زالت على حاله
قوات الاحتلال تواصل عملياتها العسكريه
ولكن هناك خبر اخر يجب ان نتحدث عنه وهو
خبر كان مفرحا للفلسطينيين وتحديدا للاسرى
الفلسطينيين كان من المفترض ان يكون اليوم
في تمام الساعه السادسه من صباح هذا اليوم
ان يخوض اكثر من 2000 اسير وتحديدا
37 اسيرا فلسطينيا
اضرابا مفتوحا عن الطعام كان يتوقع ان
يكون الاضراب الاقصى والاطوار ولكن مع
جلسات طويله وصعبه جدا تقرر ان ينتهي هذا
الاضراب وان لا يخضوه الاسرى بعد موافقه
الشباك الاسرائيلي على مطالب الاسرى شكرا
لك يا جيفارا البوديري ممارسه الجزيره من
غرب رام الله